many of us take a solid internet
connection for granted at home at work
surfing the web on the go but there's
recent data from the FCC that finds that
more than 8 million American homes and
businesses Nationwide do not have access
to high-speed broadband internet service
Wichita shows us how many Americans are
struggling to get online and what the
government is now doing to bridge that
digital divide
this may be the the best that it gets
when Amanda Moore can't get on the web
it's not responding she doesn't just
reset her router or modem like many of
us would
Moore takes her laptop for a ride up the
hill behind her house on the hunt for a
hot spot it's kind of like you share
your favorite place to shop and we share
our favorite places to get signal Moore
lives in Clay County West Virginia a
state where the FCC estimates about a
third of homes and businesses do not
have high-speed Broadband access while
she now often works from home for the
United Way Moore was a professional
photographer for 20 years not having the
bandwidth to upload files turned out to
be much more than an inconvenience it
sounds like
it altered your career path it did it
absolutely altered my career class I
didn't have time to wait for the
infrastructure to catch up to you know
the business that we wanted to have so I
just had to let it go Broadband isn't a
luxury anymore it's a necessity Commerce
Secretary Gina raimondo is leading the
Biden Administration 65 billion dollar
Broadband push as part of the bipartisan
infrastructure law signed in 2021
working to make it universally available
in about five years raimando's broader
mission is maintaining America's
competitiveness with China she says
internet access is critical it's really
essential to our competition so are we
at a disadvantage right now tapping into
everyone in America boys girls people of
color we're people living in rural
America will make us stronger and if
those are the people who don't have the
internet we're losing out on their
talent talent like 15 year old Jaylee
Persinger I really like this one
who does not have Broadband at her house
in haiko West Virginia how does the lack
of fast service impact your schoolwork
at home well it makes it very hard it
takes me about like a minute to five
minutes to like reconnect and by that
time with my ADHD I'm like okay is this
even like worth doing did you get on
time today at a boy Jay police principal
Richard Pettit says some students can't
connect to the internet at all we have a
lot of kids that live up in the back
collars of the area that just doesn't
have the option or they can't afford it
at home if we don't do something to
address the Gap we can only determine
that we're going to leave people behind
West Virginia along with every other
state will receive federal funding to
expand Broadband access exactly how the
billions of dollars are divvied up will
be announced by the end of this month
based on the newly released FCC coverage
map but even with the influx of cash it
may still be a long road the biggest
challenge is topography so you think
about some places out in the west or or
anywhere really with mountain ranges
with difficult physical circumstances
but we will get it done
for Amanda Moore it can't get done soon
enough would Broadband access make your
life better Broadband access would make
me probably seeing and dancing
yeah it would make my life easier it
would make everybody's life a lot easier
the federal government is not just
trying to expand Broadband access it's
also trying to lower the cost the
affordable connectivity program offers
subsidies to those who qualify to
purchase a computer and pay monthly
internet bills more than 18 and a half
million U.S households have already
enrolled in full disclosure my parents
in rural West Virginia where I grew up
are among those who do not have access
to broadband so I've seen first and how
it can make people feel like they are
stuck in time
and double full disclosure it includes
my mom's house where she's lived for 25
years in West Virginia
and doesn't have internet to download
pictures of grandkids we should thank
you very much it's an issue that really
matters